you know usually they'll say well you're
do me talking is so-and-so and they have
a clip and I would say maybe 70% of the
time the clip is kind of underwhelming
if you're talking to an actor or it's
not often even as good as the show
itself you guys sent along a clip that
is riveting I know we're gonna show a
little bit of a condensed version of it
but this clip is one of my it's just one
of the best clips I've seen in a long
time it's got an amazing stunts in it
we're in the desert this is episode 508
this wonderful episode directed by Vince
Gilligan and we all suffered a lot to
make it and the characters are suffering
in it and I can we talk about it for a
second after let's watch it let's show
it and roll it just walk in here
[Music]
yeah it is I just want to say the driver
of that truck is Cory Eubanks he's one
of the best if not the best stunt driver
in the world and Cory is a super nice
guy and if you've seen a car flip in any
movie over the last 10 years he's
probably in it and in fact I showed that
clip to stunt people and they said is
that Cory Eubanks in there that without
seeing him right they can tell by the
way he flips a truck
it says crazy stunts but it's an amazing
it's it's in a very tense scene and I'm
sure anyone who hasn't completely caught
up with better call Saul will be if they
just see a second of that clip will be
like all right time to catch up well
make sure I get the word out the season
5 finale of better call Saul aired
tonight on AMC all episodes from the
fifth season of better call Saul are
available to watch on AMC comm and it is
absolutely superb
so congratulations Bob thanks buddy
another great season and thank you so
much for talking to me and I really do
send you the best wishes for your son I
hope he's feeling better he's great and
thank you for sharing that personal your
personal touch with all of this because
I think that's very helpful for people
to pick up on who are watching right now
yeah all right well everybody stay safe
and thanks Conan's great to see you
great to see you too
thank you very much Bob and take care
all right take care